si on veut réussir cette bataille de
plein emploi il faut pas simplement
verser le rsa il faut accompagner
demandé et c'est le contrat de confiance
un engagement cc 15 amateurs d'activités
d'insertion de formation
si on trouve se présentant aujourd'hui
les médias le candidat on vous a entendu
notre main si vous me permettez je le
lis je sais que je n'arrivais plus là on
va passer à la jeunesse maintenant mais
je la glisse quand même une grande
voiture des horloges ici et c'est pas
vous monsieur candidats petits tyrans
ridicule ouateux les super les roitelets
8 à 7
valérie pécresse pour l'instant c'est
marine le pen d'après les sondages de
percy stow qui est au deuxième arrêté de
croire les sondages
ou pas voilà si on écoute bien
il ya du bruit de la forêt qui ce qui se
superposent qui se mélangent avec le
bruit de la mer
plus les oiseaux
ça c'est le son du danemark
quand même
quand vous demandez aux français est ce
que vous aimez les gens qui habitent en
ville ou est ce qu'elle vous aimez les
gens qui habitent à la campagne les gens
qui habitent à la campagne d'aujourd'hui
sont beaucoup plus aimés effectivement
que les gens qui habitent en ville les
gens qui votent sont beaucoup plus aimé
que les gens qui ne votent pas les gens
qui sont vaccinées aussi sont beaucoup
plus aimé que les gens non vaccinés et
les personnes athées donc qui ne croient
pas dans différentes religions qui ne
croient pas un dû en particulier sont
beaucoup plus aimé ça c'est pas bien
c'est pas bien c'est aux états unis ils
abandonnent leurs chiens car il le
salin vente et j'aurais pas pu excusez
moi voilà c'est vraiment des gens qui
sont contre le mariage pour tous tous
évidemment alors avoué dans mais c'est
ridicule de reprocher à son chien d'être
un peu plus que le meilleur ami de
l'homme après bon apparemment le club
était un peu dans tous ses états quand
on passait du mylène farmer et du
etienne daho mais bon on peut pas juger
les gens là dessus non plus écoutez
afrique sébastien broucke pub est ouvert
à tous et patrick sébastien
moi j'ai testé musique de camping et ce
point stadium annie beethoven beethoven
et je parle pas du chien bonne vanne
giovani it all patrick sébastien
attentats du beethoven à l'aide je donne
moi nerfs d'une d'une musique de
beethoven vas-y que je connaissais du
jazz en une fois que mon achi ah bah oui
ben oui
oui
honda chihab rue we
[Musique]
will merci semble il me sort mais c'est
à vérifier il me semble que a annoncé
par téléphone qui sonne à mon avis était
acquis s'il appelle ses petits enfants
qui sommes demandés si violent que tu
peux venir
c'était qui est ce qu est ce qui s j'en
sais rien mais il me semble non ces
masques et non est-ce que vous avez des
nouvelles donnes de marine le pen on se
sert vous regarde pas ainsi nous
on se dit
ça va c'est non non non non non ça ça me
ça vous regarde passer les histoires
personnelles donc ça veut dire oui
comment ça veut dire oui bah vous en
déduisez ce que vous voulez mais je veux
pas parler de ma vie familiale et
personnelle ici à dessouder comme les
doigts des symboles des domaines ouais
on est
soudés ouais
cette notion solidarité qui est un fait
social et on était et ça résonne pas mal
avec l'actualité actuel à force de dire
on te le dire à partir vraiment un
barjot arrive tout est possible la
preuve il est incontrôlable comme
l'était son prédécesseur à cette époque
là et on a affaire à de l'horreur de
l'enclos humaine voilà on peut dire ça
il n'ya pas d'autre mot
mais au bout du rouleau et au bout